[Music]
in our first two lectures we discussed
some of the defining characteristics of
the study of matter and its properties
we defined a few of those properties and
how we communicate them
we saw how chemists basically study
everything but that we do so on a scale
unique to our science the scale of atoms
and molecules we saw some of the ways in
which chemists deal with the minut scale
of chemistry using scientific notation
to express huge or minuscule numbers we
also saw how sometimes we even create
our own units to make measuring critical
values like distance masses and amounts
easier so what should we measure and
characterize first where do we begin our
journey together well as strange as it
may sound after all the lip service that
I just paid to matter in the preceding
lectures I'm going to spend this lecture
focused on something which has
practically no mass at all today we're
going to talk about light
so why am i bending my own definition of
chemistry in lecture 3 of the course
well the answer is quite simple because
it's light that we often rely upon to
probe the properties of matter at the
atomic and molecular level the word
light to chemists is really better
defined as electromagnetic radiation in
common discussion we tend to use the
term light to mean that portion of the
electromagnetic spectrum which we can
see but in truth there is much more to
light than what we can see with our eyes
and it will broach that topic very soon
but for now let's think about visible
light because it's what most of us are
used to thinking about
in general light interacts with matter
in several ways it can undergo
absorption emission reflection
refraction and diffraction now you
probably observe most if not all of
these kinds of interactions within your
own eyes on a daily basis you put on
sunglasses whose lenses absorb light to
protect your eyes you flip a light
switch to induce matter inside of a bulb
to emit light you use reflected light in
the mirror in the morning as you get
ready for the day if you walk by a fish
tank or look through a glass of water
you've probably observed the effects of
refraction as objects seem to be in one
location when observed through the
container but are actually in another
position behind it diffraction is
another phenomenon that leads to the
appearance of rainbows in the Earth's
atmosphere it happens when waves of
light interfere with one another as they
interact with particles in our
atmosphere all of us use the interaction
of light and matter to learn about our
surroundings on a daily basis what
chemists do is often no different though
sometimes a little bit more complex so
why should a chemist be so concerned
with light well think about this when
you step outside on a sunny day you can
feel the warmth of the sun's rays on
your face right so why does your face
feel warm it feels warm because the
light is acting as a vehicle for energy
light interacts with atoms and molecules
in very specific ways delivering and
transporting energy that we can measure
using devices as simple and familiar as
the human eye or as complex and
technical as million-dollar electronic
devices many techniques employed by the
modern chemist to characterize matter
use electromagnetic radiation light to
do so no matter how you look at it when
studying the properties of atoms and
molecules light is almost always part of
the equation
anytime you look at an object you're
collecting information about how light
interacts with that object the
absorption emission reflection
refraction or dispersion that you'd
observe depends on the atomic and
molecular properties of the material
involved so one could say
that in order to metaphorically shine a
light on atomic and molecular structures
of matter we have to literally shine a
light on that matter exactly how
chemists use light to study matter is a
topic that we'll investigate in future
lectures but before we can begin
characterizing how light interacts with
matter we first need to understand light
itself so during this lecture and the
next we're going to spend a bit of time
getting familiar with light from the
perspective of a chemist light is
something so familiar to us that we
often take it for granted but have you
ever stopped and contemplated what
exactly is light well what is light made
of how does it move through space and
how does it carry energy it's light
simply a disturbance in matter like
sound or seismic waves or is light
actually matter itself a stream of
particles moving in a beam these
questions perplexed great thinkers as
early as the time of ancient Greece when
Aristotle espoused one of the first
theories on the nature of light
describing it as a disturbance in one of
his proposed elements air this
description makes a little bit of sense
because it's consistent with light being
a wave which we know from experience can
move and carry energy
around the same time though Democritus
another Greek philosopher posited that
light might instead consist of very
small indivisible particles something
akin to atoms but with an identity and
make up all their own this idea also
makes some sense a stream of particles
would move and carry energy with it as
well although both of these theories
about the nature of light would seem to
explain its ability to carry energy they
also appear to be diametrically opposed
to one another it would seem that light
has to be one or the other a wave or a
stream of particles
neither Aristotle nor Democritus had the
necessary technology to test their
theory scientifically of course and this
left the true nature of light up to
debate in their time now little did
either of these great thinkers know that
their debate over the composition of
light would have to wait more than 2,000
years to finally be resolved
fast forward those 2000 years even as
Europe was exiting the Dark Ages Isaac
Newton and his contemporaries were
carrying on the struggle of defining
what makes up light Newton's famous
corpuscular theory sided with Democritus
arguing that only particles can be
refracted by a prism as he so famously
had done to observe the visible spectrum
but another famous scientist of the time
Christian Huygens countered Newton's
theory by suggesting that the same
phenomenon could be explained as waves
of light propagating at slightly
different speeds through two different
media in this case air and quartz
so in the 1600s 2,000 years after
Aristotle and Democritus touched off the
discussion the debate over the particle
or wave composition of light seemed no
closer to a conclusion in this lecture
and the next we are going to consider
this age-old debate using some of the
first scientific observations brought to
bear on the question and today we're
going to hear the case for the wave
nature of light when I say the word wave
what comes to your mind first maybe you
thought of waves of water lapping
against your favorite Beach spot perhaps
it conjured thoughts of sound as it
travels through the atmosphere or shock
waves from an earthquake moving through
the earth's sub-surface these are all
fine examples of waves but there is an
even more common but slightly less
obvious type of wave that we encounter
on a daily basis
waves of electromagnetic radiation light
they're almost constantly passing by us
and even through us now we can look at
water waves as they move across the
ocean or shock waves from an explosion
as they radiate outward through the air
but the wave nature of light itself
isn't as easy to see it eluded some of
the greatest thinkers of the human race
so how do we know that light is a wave
answer that question we have to pay a
visit to an English physicist by the
name of Thomas Young born in 1773 young
grew up studying the work of Isaac
Newton and I'm sure that young had a
great deal of respect for Newton's work
but he wasn't buying Newton's
corpuscular theory and as a young
researcher he set out to disprove it
made many contributions to the science
of physics but arguably his greatest is
an experiment that seemed to prove
indisputably that light consisted of
waves not only that but it was such a
simple and elegant proof that it could
be verified by anyone using items that
you might have right in your own home
don't believe me watch this salt sugar
vinegar water all common everyday
ingredients that you'll find in your
kitchen at home and we tend to think of
these materials primarily as things that
we bake with but those are also
chemicals and that gives us a unique
opportunity in our kitchens occasionally
to learn a little bit about chemistry
without having to go into the laboratory
so from time to time we'll come here to
the kitchen and I'll try to show you
some things that you can do and maybe a
few things you've already done that
illustrate the chemical principles that
we're discussing and today's discussion
of light is our first opportunity but
before we get to that let me talk a
little bit about how to safely do some
of these experiments in your kitchen
although it's a relatively safe place to
be we still want to protect ourselves as
though we were in a laboratory and so
I'll be doing that as well so I brought
along a few pieces of personal
protective equipment to be absolutely
sure that I leave this demonstration in
the same condition that I came in now
the first of those are chemical safety
glasses these are impact-resistant
lenses with a curved brow and side
splash guards so that if any liquid gets
splashed into the air during my
demonstration or any solid material
comes towards my eyes my eyes will be
protected properly since today we'll be
working with laser light I've also
brought some special protective laser
glasses now these are very inexpensive
and easy to find online and it's
important that you get the right color
and I'll show you this one more time but
let's take a look at it right now
as well I've chosen red and I haven't
chosen red because that's my favorite
color I've chosen red because the laser
I'll be working with is a green laser so
that might seem a little strange right
why did I choose red glasses to protect
my eyes from green light well the reason
is that the glasses appear red to us
because if
I turn on my red laser you see that red
laser light goes straight through the
glasses these glasses don't absorb red
light on the other hand when I shine
green light on these glasses which
hopefully I won't do it all but just in
case I do they will absorb it because
green is the complementary color of red
so be absolutely sure you understand
which color glasses you need if you want
to try this experiment at home
occasionally I'll also use some nitrile
protective gloves and these can be
purchased at your local grocery or
hardware stores relatively inexpensively
and they'll protect your hands from some
of the deleterious effects of some of
the chemicals that we're going to work
with like strong salt solutions in
vinegar so without any further delay
let's think a little bit about Thomas
Young's experiment and how he finally
settled the two-thousand-year-old debate
over whether light is a wave or part
to begin this experiment I'm going to
use a green laser and I've already
attached this green laser to a little
holding mechanism here on a ring stand
you won't have to necessarily do this
you can hold these in your hands but to
make it a little bit easier for the
purposes of our demonstration I'll be
doing that and just to demonstrate to
you really quickly that I've chosen the
right safety glasses here you recall how
it looked when I shined my red light
through the glasses this is the green
laser and this is the green laser
through the glasses should be able to
see very clearly they're they're
absorbing the light so these glasses
will protect me just in case a little
bit of this laser light bounces back and
I'll put that right back where it came
from no right and we're ready to go so I
have my laser ready to go I have my eye
protection ready to go as well now the
next thing I need to do is create the
famous double slit and to do that I'm
going to use a pocket comb so a pocket
comb that has very fine teeth the finer
the better is going to provide what we
need to create a double slit and all I
need to do is cover up this comb so that
only one of the teeth is exposed
creating a small gap on either side for
light to pass through so I'm going to do
that now using my black electrical tape
I like to place the comb on a nice
bright white piece of paper that way I
can see the teeth as best as possible so
that only one tooth and the gap between
it and its neighboring tooth is exposed
and then I'll place that piece of tape
down nice and tight I'll do the same
thing on the net on the adjacent tooth
to create my second slit so I'll take
another piece of tape very very
carefully place that
over the comb there and if I hold it
over the paper hopefully this will show
well you can see that there is a slit
right there actually two slits for one
right next to the other so that gives
two potential pathways from my light
beam to pass through so now it's time to
finally recreate Young's experiment so
to do this all I have to do is point my
green laser beam at the slit that I have
created the double slit that I've
created in the comb so I have one
prepared here and I'm just going to set
that up so that it projects onto a wall
I'll put my laser in place and because I
have to cite this laser very
specifically so that it hits that that
being that means I have to look at it
very closely and it's going to be very
close to this reflective tape so I'm
going to put my eye protection on now
and I'll turn on my laser so now we can
see what's going on here a single beam
passes through two slits we would expect
if they're particles to see two dots on
the wall but instead I see a linear
array of dots many many many small dots
of green light and an effect like that
in a system like this can only be
produced by a wave young of course
didn't have lasers but he did have
sunlight and what Jung observed was the
same phenomenon that we just did white
light focused on a double slit created a
similar interference pattern
so what do those lines of dots in our
laser projection really mean how do they
prove that lights a wave well it's true
that a beam of particles should it
produce just two dots in that system and
that's easily understood and very
clearly disproven by what we saw but we
haven't yet answered the question how
does the pattern confirm wave theory
well remember we saw multiple evenly
spaced bands of light these bands form
because as light waves pass through the
slits they radiate outward from them and
this creates a pattern of interference
in which waves generated at the
different slits occasionally interfere
this creates the fanned out pattern of
light bands that we saw in our
experiment so at last we have proof that
light must be a wave and because it's a
wave light has all the same
characteristics as any other way the
most important of these characteristics
for our discussions will be wave length
velocity and frequency
here's an example of the kind of wave
that we can think about when describing
light a regular repeating wave now this
wave has repeating troughs and peaks and
they're always occurring the same
distance from one another now we call
that distance between neighboring Peaks
or troughs a waves wavelength the
wavelength is often represented using a
lowercase Greek letter lambda and that's
the convention that we're going to use
in this course now set the wave in
motion at a constant speed now the speed
of a light wave would be about three
times ten to the eighth meters per
second fast enough to circle the earth
in about a tenth of a second or reach
the Sun in just eight minutes so for our
demonstration we're going to have to go
a little bit slower but let's get this
way moving anyway now I'd like you to
notice that when we do this equivalent
points on neighboring waves we'll pass a
position at regular intervals now this
is known as a frequency which is
commonly shown using a lowercase Greek
letter nu we report this in units of
cycles per second also known as Hertz
you're probably most familiar with this
unit from its application and FM radio
where the station's frequency refers to
the frequency of radiation used as a
carrier signal to broadcast at radio
stations transmission for example 103.5
megahertz means that the carrier signal
has 100 3,500,000 cycles per second as
it passes by
now consider this if I double the
wavelength look at what happens
fewer Peaks pass by per unit time so
wavelength and frequency are inversely
related to one another through a
constant equal to a waves speed this
could get a bit complicated except for
the fact that the speed of light is
constant so when we limit our discussion
to waves of light wavelength and
frequency can be easily inter converted
using this relationship lambda equals C
over nu where C is the constant speed of
light 3.0 times 10 to the 8th meters per
second so light has wave-like properties
which means that we can measure these
characteristics and classify light based
on those properties Isaac Newton's
himself handily proved that light could
be separated by passing it through a
prism at the appropriate angle and when
he did this he demonstrated what we
commonly call white light is actually a
collection of many different colors of
light Newton coined the term spectrum to
describe this collection of different
color lights
scientists today know that these
different colored lights are the result
of slight variations in their
wavelengths in this case with visible
light we're talking about wavelengths
that range from about 400 to about 800
nanometers to put that into perspective
some of the smallest cells in your body
are about 10 micrometers wide or 100
times larger than the wavelength of
light that we can see now remember that
light is a term that most of us use to
describe electromagnetic radiation your
eyes can detect but in truth we would be
talking about visible light in a
situation like this our eyes are a
remarkable product of our evolution but
they have their limitations and in this
case it turns out to be a pretty severe
limitation
you see in 1800 an English researcher
named Sir William Herschel discovered
that prisms separate not only visible
light but an invisible form of light
that falls beyond the red end of the
spectrum he named this infrared light
because of its location beyond the red
just a year later in 1801 Johann Wilhelm
Ritter discovered another invisible form
of light capable of darkening silver
salts and this type of light fell
outside of the blue or violet end of the
visible spectrum so Ritter called this
ultraviolet light so light comes in far
more forms than that which we can see
with the unaided human eye even Herschel
and Ritter couldn't possibly have
guessed just how far outside of the
visible spectrum light really goes it's
actually quite staggering scientists
characterize each region of the
electromagnetic spectrum based on the
wavelength of light that produces it and
these wavelengths can span a remarkable
range of distances varying from lengths
greater than a mile to smaller than the
diameter of a single atom when we line
all of these possible wavelengths up
from shortest to longest we can see what
a truly small slice of the spectrum
human beings can see with the unaided
eye
so let's take a short tour of the
electromagnetic spectrum as we
understand it today here it is at the
extremely short wavelength end of the
spectrum are gamma rays these extremely
high-energy rays have wavelengths so
small that they're even smaller than
atoms next in line are x-rays light with
a wavelength just about equal to the
size of an atom and x-rays have the
ability to expose photographic film just
the way visible light does but they
carry so much energy that they can
penetrate flesh but not bone and this
has led to their use in medical imaging
as we'll soon see
now the former property allowed many
researchers to use them as scientific
tools in this way our next stop is
ultraviolet radiation wavelengths of
ultraviolet light tend to be near the
size of many molecules they're just
about 100 nanometers across and finally
we reach the visible light that's small
slice of the electromagnetic spectrum
that we use every day to observe the
world through our eyes but a slight
increase in the wavelength again takes
us into the infrared region of the
spectrum infrared radiation is emitted
by matter naturally around the
temperatures that we experience here on
the surface of the earth now this makes
them very interesting from a number of
potential applications not the least of
which is being able to detect the
presence of warm objects in what we
perceive to be complete darkness
next comes microwave radiation which has
wavelengths around 1 meter microwaves
have always been fascinating to
scientists but in recent decades they've
become best known for their use in
exciting water molecules to generate
heat in the form of microwave ovens and
our final stop on our short tour of the
electromagnetic spectrum takes us to
radio waves waves so long that their
wavelengths can easily span distances of
miles of course the most familiar
technology associated with radio waves
is the transmission of audio information
but just as with all other forms of
radiation we'll learn in this course
that radio waves have other properties
and applications exploited by
to help us understand the world around
us from highly toxic gamma rays emitted
by pulsars at the edge of the universe
all the way down to radio waves which
can pass through humans and buildings
without causing any apparent harm light
has a remarkable capacity to carry
varying amounts of energy through space
maybe even more remarkable than that is
that chemists have devised ways to use
all forms of light as probes for the
structures and functions of molecules so
let's summarize what we've discussed so
far in this lecture we focused our
attention on light which can interact
with matter in a number of ways that can
help us to understand our universe we
discussed the millennia long debate over
the true nature of light and in this
lecture we considered the wave nature of
light which describes light waves in
terms of wavelength frequency and
velocity we saw how the wave nature of
light is easily verified using a very
simple experiment conceived by Thomas
Young in 1803 then we learned about the
discovery of infrared light and
ultraviolet light by Herschel and Ritter
discoveries that brought to our
attention that there is a tremendous
continuum of electromagnetic radiation
most of which we can't see with our own
eyes we also saw how the wave properties
of light like wavelength and frequency
help us to organize electromagnetic
radiation into a continuum known as the
electromagnetic spectrum so it would
seem that the debate has been settled
but appearances can be deceiving
not long after Young's discovery yet
another great scientist made a discovery
that would once again ignite the debate
over the true nature of light we're
going to hear his case for the particle
nature of light in our next lecture
[Music]
occasionally as time allows in the
course we're going to take some of the
knowledge that we gained in a lecture or
two and apply them to a problem and I
like to call challenge problems and this
lecture gives us our first opportunity
to do that so let's ask a question about
electromagnetic radiation and see if we
can answer it using what we've learned
we're all pretty familiar with FM radio
now my particular favorite station here
in the DC area broadcasts at a frequency
of 100 3.5 megahertz that's the
frequency of the electromagnetic carrier
signal that's bringing that radio
station to my stereo in my car or my
home but the question here is if that's
the frequency of that carrier signal
then what is the wavelength of that
radiation they should be related to one
another using an equation that we've
already learned lambda equals C over nu
remember the proportionality between
wavelength and frequency is described by
this calculation so let's answer this
question now we're going to start with a
wavelength and of course our target is
to know how many meters that wavelength
is so let's use the information from our
problem 103.5 megahertz which is
actually a hundred 3.5 million Hertz so
I have to be sure that I include that in
my calculation doing my unit analysis
here I have megahertz cancel reciprocal
seconds cancel and my answer will be in
units of meters this is what I want so
now I can run the math the speed of
light divided by 100 three point five
megahertz with a correction factor for
the fact that megahertz is a million
Hertz I get about three meters so the
wavelength of that radiation carrying
the radio signal to me is about 3 meters
long it's taller than I am now let's try
a different problem with the type of
radiation with which you might be less
familiar x-rays now x-ray
crystallography is a technique used by
scientists to divine the structures of
many molecules x-rays are useful for
this purpose because they have extremely
short wavelengths as a general rule you
need a wavelength that's at least as
small as whatever you're trying to a
serve so when it comes to observing
atoms we obviously can't use visible
light the wavelengths are just too long
but one of the more popular x-rays for
this technique is one that is 0.71
nanometers this is generated by
electrically exciting molybdenum atoms
so our question for the day is what's
the frequency of that radiation if its
wavelength
is 0.71 nanometers
[Music]
we have to use a slightly different
version of our equation right notice
that I've isolated frequency now so my
calculation now reads frequency equals
the speed of light divided by the
wavelength which is just a mathematical
rearrangement of what we use previously
so I'm after units of frequency meaning
I'm going to put in my C divided by
lambda and of course I'm going to have
to remember that in this case I'm
dealing with the wavelength that was
given to me in nanometers but the speed
of light that we used was in meters per
second so to correct for that I'm going
to put in a factor of 10 to the ninth
nanometers equal to one meter unit
analysis tells me that nanometers will
cancel as well meters leaving me with
reciprocal seconds and the answer that I
get is 4.2 times 10 to the 17th Hertz
that's 420 peda hurts not megahertz not
gigahertz not even terahertz but 420
pedda Hertz nearly a billion billion
cycles per second passed by when one of
these x-rays is moving
[Music]